the Joe Rogan experience you know again
you can argue I mean we I don't want to
get into a political discussion Trump is
an unusual character and you know they
certainly they tell you I know Wow well
that's gonna be there that'll be
headlines how about that fella that's
from England that looks like the boys
Johnson yeah I was just there last week
when when he went over to Buckingham
Palace and and you know was asked by the
Queen to form the new government he
accepted and so you know he's he's an
interesting character he went to Eton he
went to Oxford he's he's proven himself
to be extremely adept at getting getting
elected and most importantly he looks
like Trump's baby brother yeah yeah you
know what ice like he's [ __ ] up like
Trump's dad went over to England and
bang some waitress and bam next thing
you know look at the two of them
together get the [ __ ] out of here this
is my this I got everybody might sent me
this one it's a South Park one
it's him with a bike helmet on it's
that's the best side oh yeah I mean
literally looks like a young Trump
cousin or a brother so I'm like but he's
promised you know he's promised there
they're out as far as brexit goes by you
know Halloween by 31 October they're
done and so it's done with the whole
European Union yeah well that's what
that's what they're saying that
basically now that what they're
concerned about of course is that it's a
hard hard exit right no deal but he's
saying doesn't matter if that's the case
then that's what we've got to do and
there's a lot of people it's it's it's
interesting the dynamic is a little bit
like here in the US right if you're in
the Northeast Corridor in Washington New
York whatever Boston or you're out here
on the west coast and you you you tend
to view the world differently than
everything else the rest of the mass of
the country right which is why people
lost their minds and they thought you
know how could Trump possibly get
elected mm-hmm the UK is a little bit
like that that brexit vote came around
and everybody in London was convinced
that were you know it's giving ninety
five percent you know we're not leaving
and so when it came time and they
devoted to leave in 2001 it was 16 the
people in London
lost their minds they couldn't believe
it and they still to this day think
everybody else is just an idiot right so
there's there's a similarities there
which is I
think why in part Trump meal feels sort
of that this kinship with Boris Johnson
hmm
but yeah so he's Boris Johnson has said
that's it we're out of here you know
maybe we can get a deal if we can't
doesn't matter we're still leaving and
it'll be interesting to see what happens
but you know he's not he's not unpopular
what's the argument for them leaving
what's the pro brexit argument do you
really want to have your country your
sovereign nation run by a bunch of
faceless technocrats living in Brussels
who have really zero interest in your
sovereign nation right that's at the
heart of it it's not an economic
decision people always make that that
problem with brexit they always say well
from an economic perspective this is not
a good thing well the deal at heart
isn't an economic concern it's it's the
issue of sovereignty it's the issue of
being run again by Brussels and and and
sort of the business morass of of
regulations that they've imposed the
inability for the UK to make their own
decisions about trade and so there's a
you know there's a good argument in that
regard is it going to be a financial
problem for them it's not gonna be a
disaster like some people you know throw
out there and say oh my god this is
gonna you know the UK is going down the
toilet fast that won't happen but it'll
be there'll be an upheaval if they if
they you know leave without a deal but
they'll adjust because everybody will
want to do deals right they want to do
trade it's not like Germany and France
which are the only two partners in the
EU that really matter
from yeah I know I can't believe I just
so what's the what's the staying in the
European Union argument show everybody
not racist yeah
global globalism you know it's we're all
working together and isn't this a
wonderful thing and look at you know all
the benefits of it free movement and you
know that free movement you know didn't
really work that well from from France
and Germany's perspective you know they
don't like to talk about that anymore
Fryman is basically what we enjoy in the
United States though isn't it I mean if
you look at the United States and
relative size in comparison to Europe
we're basically commensurate right yeah
in terms of the contiguous United States
exhibit yeah yeah and we all speak the
same language but I'm talking about I'm
talking about immigration policies I'm
not talking about
within the EU no no I understand but I
mean even in immigration right like the
size of these countries in comparison
the size of states like Texas is
basically bigger than a lot of [ __ ]
right European nations right yeah yeah
it's it is that argument sort of the
immigration argument much like some of
the other arguments comes down from the
UK's perspective on don't tell us what
to do right and you know maybe there's
still an element of look we you know we
were an empire that controlled most of
the planet for a while you know we'd
like to you know have a little bit more
say in what we're doing so there's an
independent streak the problem is from a
use perspective is if they do leave and
it's not a disaster then other countries
are gonna line up right and and Italy
maybe would be the next one so it'll be
interesting to see what happens but yeah
Bojo as they call them is an interesting
cat not unlike our president